when you slapped uh korean zombies
manager who's uh
[Laughter]
chin's friends with him and chin was
like can you believe ryan did that i'll
go [ __ ] yeah like brian
doesn't stop talking about it
bronzer you're free
is he not his manager he just deals with
his social media you don't have to talk
about it tonight i was just saying
like to me that's that was the other
that's out of character for you to do
that yeah it was
knowing you like that was out of
character if you had any idea of what my
week was like that week you would
understand like stress just sit like
i don't know if tikki's getting mad if i
speak right now
who's getting tj
would that provide some context that we
didn't know like you know hey put it
this way i got in a fight
on a tuesday
i got in a fight on a friday
some crazy [ __ ] happened on a thursday
so you're just i was on a bomb on that
one and then you saw him yeah and i
wasn't getting in trouble like to the
point where like it's like
some [ __ ] happened uh
in vegas and [ __ ]
like right the friday before that fight
got him
got a fight
uh
[ __ ] cops had had his like belly down
and [ __ ] and the guy looks at me like
brian like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] do you
i just i can't think i just gotta act
right i'm like oh my career like
i see again i see four guys on you that
have something yeah we are uh trained
not to think yeah i mean like you think
you lose but then when you unleash that
[ __ ] side of you and you then you see
the aftermath you're like [ __ ] yeah and
then the cops don't see what happened
dude
[Laughter]
but the cops saw me let me go which was
good nice and then
uh
yeah i was already see not all cops guys
not all cops
and uh
so yeah and then i [ __ ]
told the homeboy if i saw him i'd slap
him
on his social media right he was at the
end like when i talked to korean zombies
said he wasn't whatever i think it was
just a misunderstanding misunderstanding
i don't know i like that i like yeah i
like those guys but i just felt like bro
like in my opinion was like just stay
out of it like the fight's already
happening you we're not getting
pay-per-view buyers
yeah we like i went to korea i showed
nothing but love over there i was
respectful even when he told me like hey
dude it was my team yep and i said like
it is like [ __ ] it bro like just yeah we
don't have to be [ __ ] every fight
to each other to promote it
like i think we're two good fighters
it's not your nature it's not natural
for you so when this little guy like
when this guy starts kind of acting up
on social media and like kind of
like in my
the way i took it was like he's kind of
puffing his chest i'm like hold up
[ __ ] like you're not a regular
guy he's a rapper where
where uh
like if someone talks [ __ ] okay but if
like bro we're we're going to run into
each other yeah i'm going to see you
yeah it's not like something inside yeah
and it's like i'm and i'm nice with
everyone yeah i don't have issues with
anyone rather than even vocaloids
whatever like i don't have issues with
anyone yeah
so i was like bro just stop that [ __ ]
and he still kind of kept fighting all
right [ __ ] like
yeah wait till i see you yeah
and then i
i didn't even know he was there until
like i looked back and i was like
[ __ ] he's there
i swear that's what ran through my head
i was like [ __ ] like i'm already in the
world of [ __ ] from this week we're like
well i guess i gotta slap again and
that's what i told myself [ __ ] dude i
can't like i have to be a man of my word
too
and i almost and i even want to either
like and i walked up like i jumped over
the chair and i was just like look i
don't want to do this and i still didn't
realize i still didn't even i wasn't
even sure if it was him or not yeah and
i said hey [ __ ] what's your
[ __ ] name korean people no no
yeah you have to ask his name i was just
like hey [ __ ] what's your name
yeah
if you would be like hey bro
relax
i want to [ __ ] did [ __ ] yeah but what
i but he was just like
like he was like oh like jay park like
the way he said i go oh yeah
[ __ ] like all right
and then it was like
[ __ ] all right that just happened
but if you're gonna do it's probably the
best place to do it yeah